[Musique]
écoute-moi bien tu touches encore une
fois cette poêle sans demander et je te
brise les doigts c'est clair
[Musique]
moi c'est mon lit elle va durer combien
de temps elle est différente je suis
Vanessa je la fréquente depuis plusieurs
semaines
et je m'appelle soie elle a de multiples
personnalités
[Musique]
elle est comme les montagnes russes il y
a tellement de choses que je ne sais pas
sur elle
d'habitude je suis plutôt le gars qui
baisse les bras mais cette fois je ne
veux pas tu leur trouves toujours
quelque chose qui cloche elle laisse du
maquillage sur mes serviettes blanches
et elle réorganise ma collection de
figurines tu as toujours une excuse
pourquoi celle-là je veux juste la
comprendre et surtout ne lubrise pas le
cœur c'est de loin la petite amie que je
préfère
je veux l'aider elle a été blessée
auparavant si seulement elle pouvait
voir ce que je vois
[Musique]
je t'ai déjà dit que tu peux sortir avec
toutes les filles que tu veux pourvu
qu'elles te mettent pas en retard à vrai
dire elles sont cinq tu relèves ton
tablier et tu sors
[Musique]